erst einmal sind ja nicht alle sind
städten mit risikogebieten zweitens
glaube ich ist des reisenden den
herbstferien meine sagte setzt auch
etwas überbewertet ich glaube schon dass
man in der verhältnismäßigkeit
selbstschutz und schutz von dritten auch
abwägen kann lasse ich mich auf was ein
was ich selber nicht im blick habe
ansonsten gilt das einhalten der regeln
tatsächlich kontakte so weit es möglich
ist auch zurückzuführen abstandsgebot
hygiene die erste jetzt auch zunehmend
lüften sich an die regeln halten und wir
als öffentliche seite und das tun wir
und das möchte ich schon noch sagen
warum waren wir so erfolgreich weil wir
die schnellsten von allen waren weil wir
maßnahmen schnell getroffen haben
vielleicht ist jetzt auch diese
reaktivierung des beherbergungs verbotes
eine dieser schnell maßnahmen die wir
jetzt auch nochmals in der ausprägung
noch mal genauer anschauen müssen aber
sie geben mir recht wir brauchen schon
eine rückversicherung dass infizierte
sich nicht auf reisen begeben eine
irgendwie geartete kontrolle braucht man
auch wenn die jetzige form nicht
geeignet seien